[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
une proie pour qui au juste banjo enfin
jo fangio et mort au siècle dernier
briatore
[Musique]
les détruire j'étais juste là
c'est lui qui a filé le tueur
regarde-moi screen série michael jackson
déchire ta veste comme un saint michael
jackson c'est ludo l'at-elle l'averse
accès espèce grégaire l'esstic un
problème on va devoir conduire en marche
arrière et regarde autour d'elle on
déconne pas rigolo brett hawke
j'ai besoin de toi j'ai un problème et
c'est qu'on domaine complice cette
voiture et par toi comment ça tu te fous
de moi
laisse tomber cette mercedes content
parce que j'ai cru que tu avais voulu
rouler dans ton coloma
tu connais que l'eau pour les frites
pour l'état tu comprends ça j'aime
prendre 30 balles dans la tête si je
fais comme si de rien n'était
je ne peux pas relâcher des criminels
mois
tu va le trouver et me le ramener dans
le coffre de la voiture compris
pour nous ça balance angie je suis pas
sûr mais j'ai ma petite idée
c'est ma ville mais sur ces dames yens
[Musique]